hello and welcome to this video which is
a bit different as you immediately
recognize because I want to introduce ya
book and now a chasuble product to you
that you might know maybe not know and I
think it's useful to know about it
because it is an excellent product and
an excellent concept to check out and
the book and it is actually originally
the paper book I got it I got it in
paper it's called the woodpecker method
um and it's written by XL Smith AXA
Smith and Hans chicken to Swedish
grandmasters excel as a grandmaster now
I think I think he's got the title by
now and yeah what is it all about
it's a method that was some used by T
Carlin tickle and ISM grandmaster
currently rated 2500 something his peak
rating was close to 2600 and he used
this method right before he's called
audits grand master norms and the method
is about texts tactics yeah the idea is
that you improve your tactical vision
and your tactical and your speed and
calculation by doing exercises tactics
exercises solving puzzles but to do it
in a particular way the idea is to take
a set of exercises can be a couple of
hundred thousand two thousand whatever
it is and then you solve them over the
course of a timespan ideally you do
something every day and you go through
the thousand puzzles over cause of yeah
whatever time span you have and after
you've done those 1000 T to the 1000
again and you try to be quicker
you should be quicker because you have
seen them
but still yeah you have to do it again
and you should track your speed and your
yeah accuracy how many mistakes do you
make how many do you solve correctly and
once you've done the second gap the
second to turn we do a third turn
it sounds like hard work and it is hard
work for sure to do all those exercises
again and again but um the results are
excellent tactical and actually after
doing this technical exercise packages
again and again
he scored 3 GM norms within a seven week
period as he with us this is great I
mean this is a fantastic result and it
might not be all due to that but he said
that he wanted to improve his tactics
and it seemed to work so ultimately this
method and why is it called woodpecker
it's kind of it makes sense in a way
yeah because that little bird is yeah
chipping away at Ed Wood it's like
chipping away at your technical yeah a
crew improving your tactical vision by
chipping away small stones or small
small parts of wood but tickle also is
the Swedish word for this bird so it
makes it make sense yeah so they
introduced that in in an earlier book by
by Smith that that method it was like
mentioned in passing but now there is a
book a real paper book and the main
chunk of this are the exercises you know
they have like 1000 in each I should see
it here right 1000 something exercises
more than 1000 a team and I've gotten
the book in July late your lime and I
always felt yeah I should do that you
know my tactics are not great I should
do that but it is stuff they do it with
a paper book and track all your track
your results also here you have to
basically write down like okay a
percentage of exercise
done correctly how much time did it take
and so on and yeah now this is where
Jezebel comes in the woodpecker method
is now on chasuble it's now on for a
couple of days and obviously an online
platform is the ideal way to do this
because you have all the tactics you can
solve them on screen and the program in
this case here the chespin website they
tracks all your progress it's fantastic
and the time you take to solve it
the your accuracy everything I mean
chasuble is all about this space
repetition and this is exactly what this
does
you know the idea is to like repeat it
all over again to really have this yeah
yeah to get this stored in your brain
how those patterns work and it's a
subconscious thing so how does that work
on chasuble but by the way I should
mention why I'm doing this video right
now and it is still on the intro price
yeah the the paper book is rather
expensive it is yeah 33 euros which
makes it 38 dollars or something if you
are in the u.s. something like that 37
38 and this will also be the price in
dollars on chasuble after the
introductory phase but I still think
still for two days they have the intro
price here for 25 US dollars makes it
21-0 so so which is a steal so I want to
point that out to you if you want to
improve your tactics and you basically
everybody wants to because there's room
for improvement and tactics decide most
chess games how does that work on just
about just to show if you don't know how
the chasuble looks like yeah you you
have this course and you have the the
exercise packages they start with easy
exercises see em they said they have an
intro and they have everything that is
in the book but the main chunk are the X
sighs so you would go into the exercises
here and then start to start to learn
and I can you click learn next and then
you get you get the exercise yeah okay
I'm not going to I'm not going to do
this I'm going to solve like tons of
exercise now but let's just see if I can
do one or two so black to play how do
you play yep that should win check and
now rook takes you three should
certainly win I don't see a maid now I
think it wins yeah and it is correct
yeah it gives you the time studied and
so on and it tracks all of that yeah so
you got the next one Stein it's the
house begin our 1960 white to play look
at all the checks as rook takes is six
good could be em if the pawn takes
Bishop h6 winning the Queen
I never taken the king the King captures
I've got Queenie form and then Queen
takes b7 so that move wins you're
looking at the checks is really a very
simple wait
yeah a very simple recipe oftentimes the
most forcing moves the best yeah and
then you continue and continue and again
it's rinse and repeat yeah you can
always you you also have to repeat that
so here probably III and open up the
second ring that looks correct and ruku
six
yeah and so on yeah tactics training
platform is ideal for the woodpecker
method and for what it's worth I'm doing
it now yeah I'm using this on a daily
basis doing some tactics and then I try
to I try to make more but currently I'm
working on a new chancellor project so
my time is limited but I try to do a
little bit I've done all the easy
exercise and hope to improve my tactical
play that way how is that winning how
are we winning here that looks like an
extreme position really well if I go
rook e8 Bishop takes rook takes King f2
hmm
I don't see a maid
r23 over when I can't go Queen III but
it said winning hmm okay this is a bit
of guesswork okay it's that alternative
air did you see that alternative so then
that that should win but it's not the
best yeah still doesn't count as solved
so what is winning here hmm
don't quite see it I can take the other
look maybe this is right yeah okay so
and now I saw Queen III queen king of
one and then I didn't find what wins
there should be a three maybe um Bishop
c5 Bishop c5 then it's got Queen d2 you
see I'm not great at this
but that wins a check take and push up
c5 now that wins Queen have to mate and
if the Queen goes to D - you take on f3
yeah so next ones that doesn't look too
difficult
yeah I'm trapping the Queen here that is
a motif that I know but you know if you
know the motif you're quicker and
getting all those motifs into your
system is great so if you are looking
for a way to improve your tactics check
out the woodpecker method it's um I
think I deal on a chasuble platform then
if you want to learn more about the
method by the way the quality chess
website I can yeah quality chess coach
UK can also Google the woodpecker method
yet would probably come up yeah they
have a PDF file that way you can see the
intro and read the intro and I think it
it's good additional information all
those information should also be on the
main page and in chasuble but their PDF
is nice too haven't and check yeah if
you want to get this do it down it's
cheaper and I think Sunday or Monday
something like that it would be the the
usual price and now you can get it
cheaper so make sure to check it out I
think it's an excellent way to improve
your tactics thanks for watching